>> Jesse: BIDEN'S BORDER IS
WIDE OPEN, NO DOUBT ABOUT THAT.
EVERY DAY WE BRING YOU BRAND-NEW
FOX NEWS VIDEO THAT EXPOSES THE
CRISIS.
THERE'S LITERALLY THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE COMING IN PER DAY.
20,000 MORE WAITING IN MEXICO TO
CROSS ONCE TITLE 42 ENDS.
IF YOU DARE POINT THAT OUT, THE
BIDEN WHITE HOUSE NOW THINKS
YOU'RE WORKING WITH THE CARTELS
AND SPREADING MISINFORMATION.
>> I WANT TO BE CLEAR, THE FACT
IS THE REMOVAL OF TITLE 42 DOES
NOT MEAN THE BORDER IS OPEN.
ANYONE WHO SUGGESTS OTHERWISE IS
SIMPLY DOING THE WORK OF THESE
SMUGGLERS WHO AGAIN ARE
SPREADING AND MISINFORMATION.
THE BORDER IS NOT OPEN.
SO I WANT TO BE VERY CLEAR ABOUT
THAT.
BECAUSE WE WERE DOING THE
SMUGGLERS' JOB IF WE SPREAD
MISINFORMATION.
>> Jesse: THE WHITE HOUSE
BETTER TELL THE CENTER CATS HAVE
BEEN CRITICAL OF BIDEN'S OPEN
BORDER THAT THEY ARE COLLUDING
WITH HUMANS SMUGGLERS.
>> THIS IS A HUMANITARIAN
CRISIS.
WE NEED TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT.
WE NEED TO ENSURE THAT WE HAVE A
PLAN IN PLACE.
>> CLEARLY IT'S A HUGE CONCERN
ALL ALONG THE SOUTH TEXAS
BORDER.
LAST YEAR WE CALCULATED THAT
CARTELS HAVE MADE $5 BILLION
BRING PEOPLE TO OUR SOUTHERN
BORDER.
>> PEOPLE ARE UNDERSTANDING
ACROSS THE WORLD THAT THE FACT
THAT THE SOUTHERN BORDER IS
OPEN.
>> Jesse: THIS REMINDS ME OF
THAT GAME THEY PLAY WITH RUSSIA.
FEW SAID ANYTHING, OH, YOU'RE A
RUSSIAN.
YOU'RE A SYMPATHIZER.
NOW YOU'RE A SMUGGLER
SYMPATHIZER.
>> Judge Jeanine: IS ALMOST IS
THOUGH, DON'T BELIEVE YOUR LYING
EYES.
EVEN OF TITLE 42 GOES AWAY, IT'S
STILL GOING TO BE A CLOSE
BORDER.
BUT THE TRUTH IS THAT THE BORDER
IS OPEN NOW WITH TITLE 42.
SOMEBODY OUGHT TO FIGURE OUT,
THE SMART WAY TO DO THIS THING
WOULD BE TO HAVE THEIR HEARING
RIGHT THEN AND THERE TO
DETERMINE WHETHER OR NOT THEY
ARE DESERVING OF ASYLUM.
KEEP THEM IN MEXICO, IN
DETENTION, THEY ARE ILLEGALLY
CROSSING OVER.
THEN MAKE A DECISION, DO THEY
HAVE A SIGNIFICANT, SUBSTANTIAL
ASYLUM CLAIM.
SHE IS GASLIGHTING THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE, KARINE JEAN-PIERRE.
SHE HAS BEEN DOING IT.
MAYORKAS DOES IT.
THEY SAY THE BORDER IS NOT OPEN.
THE BORDER SO OPEN IT'S
PATHETIC.
SMALL TOWNS ARE BEING OVERRUN.
THE AMAZING THING IS, THEY ARE
SAYING OH, NO, TITLE 42 IS
KEEPING PEOPLE OUT.
WHEN TITLE 42 GOES AWAY, BECAUSE
IT'S NO LONGER A PANDEMIC, THE
TRUTH IS WE ARE STILL GOING TO
KEEP IT CLOSE.
ARE YOU KIDDING ME?
YOU'RE FIGHTING IN THE
SUPREME COURT TO GET TITLE 42
OUT SO THAT THEY CAN COME IN.
WE ARE SEEING PEOPLE IN FOIL
BLANKETS, TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE.
HALF A MILLION IN ONE SECTOR
SINCE OCTOBER.
THIS COUNTRY IS BEING INVADED.
>> Jesse: TELLING THE TRUTH IS
SPREADING MISINFORMATION.
>> Dana: MIGHT AS WELL CANCEL
THE WHOLE MEDIA.
I GUESS WE DON'T NEED ANY
JOURNALISTS.
IS THAT WHAT THEY ARE SAYING?
MENTION THE RUSSIAN COMMUNIST
SYMPATHIZER, IT'S THE SAME, IF
YOU DISAGREE WITH US, YOU'RE
LIVING THE TERRORIST WIN.
IT DOESN'T WORK.
IN THIS CASE, YOU HAVE THE
VIDEO.
AS YOU SAID, DON'T BELIEVE YOUR
LYING EYES.
WE SEE IN EVERY SINGLE DAY.
FOR TWO YEARS WE'VE BEEN DOING
"AMERICA'S NEWSROOM."
THEY KEEP COMING ACROSS.
HOW MANY HAVE SAID I WOULD LIKE
TO THANK THE REPUBLICANS FOR
HELPING US GET IN HERE.
NO ONE HAS EVER SAID THAT.
THANK YOU, JOE BIDEN.
THAT COULD BE THE SMUGGLERS
THEMSELVES.
WHO HAVE MARKETING MATERIALS,
FACEBOOK PAGES TRYING TO GET
MIGRANTS TO PAY UP TO TAKE THEM
ACROSS.
THE MIGRANTS ARE BEING HURT BY
THE SMUGGLERS, THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION IS HELPING THE
SMUGGLERS BY NOT STOPPING THERE.
NOT ONLY ARE THEY NOT STOPPING
THEM BUT THEY ARE NOT STOPPING W
MUCH PENSION THOSE IN THE
UNITED STATES RIGHT NOW?
IT'S NOT STOPPING.
IT COULD KILL ALL OF US.
THAT'S HOW MUCH IS OUT THERE
RIGHT NOW.
THERE'S NOTHING THEY ARE DOING
TO STOP IT.
THEY ARE STILL PAYING FOR THEM
TO PUT KAMALA HARRIS IN CHARGE
OF THE BORDER BECAUSE SHE SAID
SHE WAS GOING TO DO SOMETHING
ABOUT IT.
SHE SAID SHE WAS GOING TO DO
ROOT CAUSES AND THEN SHE TOUCHED
THE HOT STOVE OF MEDIA CRITICISM
AND BACKED OFF COMPLETELY AND
THEY'VE HAD NO ONE DOING
ANYTHING.
THE LAST THING I WOULD SAY,
WILL HURD, FORMER CONGRESSMAN
FROM THAT AREA, HE ACTUALLY SAID
TODAY ON NEWSROOM THAT HE IS FOR
THE FIRING OF SECRETARY
MAYORKAS.
VERY MILD-MANNERED GUY,
UNDERSTANDS GOVERNMENT.
HE SAID THEY COMPLETELY DROPPED
THE BALL FOR THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
AND THAT SOMEONE HAS TO BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE.
>> Jesse: THE CARTELS ARE
HAVING THE BEST TWO YEARS
THEY'VE HAD FINANCIALLY.
>> Tom: APPARENTLY WE ARE
HELPING THEM BY SAYING THAT THE
BORDER IS OPEN.
THIS THING HAS HAPPENED OVER AND
OVER.
IT'S ACTUALLY, YOU ALMOST DON'T
BLAME THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
WERE TAKING THIS TACK BECAUSE
THE MEDIA LETS THEM GET AWAY
WITH IT.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION DO
SOMETHING WRONG, THEY DENY THAT
THEY DID IT WRONG AND THEN WHEN
YOU BRING IT UP AND THEY POINTED
OUT, THEY SAY NO, YOU'RE THE ONE
CAUSING IT BECAUSE YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT IT.
DID YOU PLAY THE MARTHA RAVITCH
CLIP?
GOVERNOR ABBOTT AND SHE SAID TO
GOVERNOR ABBOTT, THE TALKING
POINTS HAVE BEEN OUT THERE
BECAUSE SHE KIND OF PLAYED RIGHT
INTO IT.
SHE SAID GOVERNOR ABBOTT,
PRESIDENT BIDEN NEVER SAYS THAT
THERE IS AN OPEN BORDER BUT YOU
SAY IT ALL THE TIME.
AREN'T YOU THE PROBLEM?
HE WAS KIND OF LIKE, HE DIDN'T
KNOW HOW TO ANSWER.
HE SHOULD'VE SAID, ARE YOU
KIDDING ME?
ME SAYING WHAT IS OBVIOUS IS
CAUSING THE PROBLEM.
NO.
SO WE ALL KNOW THAT THE BORDERS
OPEN.
THEY ARE GOING TO CONTINUE DOING
THAT, IF THE MEDIA LETS THEM GET
AWAY WITH IT, THEY WILL DO IT
AGAIN.
>> Dana: I FORGOT TO MENTION,
ALL YOU HAVE TO DO IS GO BACK TO
THE CAMPAIGN OF 2020 AND ALL THE
DEMOCRATS, INCLUDING BIDEN
CONSISTENTLY SO THEY WERE GOING
TO DO EVERYTHING THE OPPOSITE OF
TRUMP WHEN IT CAME TO
IMMIGRATION AND THEY HAVE.
>> Jesse: HE SAID COME TO THE
BORDER.
I'M GOING TO HAVE ABBOTT ON
TONIGHT.
MAYBE HE CAN DISCUSS IT.
IS THIS A PROBLEM, THIS NEW
EXCUSE?
ARE YOU GOING TO HAVE TO RETIRE
THAT?
>> Jessica: IT'S THE
WHITE HOUSE.
THERE ARE TWO ISSUES WHERE THE
WHITE HOUSE HAS BEEN OUT OF LINE
WITH THE DEMOCRATS.
TALKING ABOUT THE BORDER AND THE
ECONOMY AND INFLATION.
REGULAR DEMOCRATS ON THE
CAMPAIGN TRAIL, SAYING THINGS
LIKE GAS COSTS TOO MUCH PRETTY
GO TO THE GROCERY STORE.
IT'S TOO MUCH.
IT'S UNSUSTAINABLE.
WE'VE GOT TO DO SOMETHING ABOUT
IT.
THEN YOU WOULD HEAR FROM THE
PRESS SECRETARY THAT EVERYTHING
WAS FINE.
OR THE PRESIDENT WOULD SAY OUR
INFLATION LEVELS ARE SO MUCH
BETTER THAN ALL THESE OTHER
COUNTRIES.
FOR SOME COUNTRIES, IT WAS TRUE.
FOR OTHERS, IT DIDN'T.
EITHER WAY IT DEFEATED THE MOST
COMMON PRINCIPLE OF POLITICS
WHICH IS DON'T TELL PEOPLE THE
THEIR LIVED EXPERIENCES IN THE
REAL EXPERIENCE OF WHAT'S GOING
ON ESPECIALLY WHEN YOU CAN SEE
IT IN THE CIRCUMSTANCE.
I REMEMBER WHEN TITLE 42 GOT
UPHELD BY THE COURTS.
MEMBER HOW MANY DEMOCRATS,
TALKING ABOUT THE RELIEF OF
THESE DEMOCRATS THAT THE COURTS
ARE TAKING CARE OF IT SO HE
COULDN'T CONTINUE UNTIL HE HAD A
POLICY.
EVEN LEFT-WING PEOPLE WHO WANTED
A MORE QUOTE HUMANITARIAN"
SOLUTION DIDN'T WANT TITLE 42 TO
GO INTO WE HAVE A VIABLE
SOLUTION.
I DON'T KNOW IF THAT BILL IS THE
ANSWER TO IT.
THE PATHWAY FOR DREAMERS.
THE BORDER SECURITY.
WE CAN'T GET RID OF TITLE 42 IN
THE --
UNTIL THERE IS SOME SOLUTION.
>> Jesse: TELL
KARINE JEAN-PIERRE THAT I SAID
IT'S TIME TO RETIRE THAT EXCUSE.
LET HER KNOW I SAID IT'S TOAST.
>> Judge Jeanine: 25 BILLION
FOR THE WALL OR SOMETHING ELSE.
>> Jessica: LIKE